just before we get started can I ask all
our members if you've got copies of the
addendum everyone seen that we've
circulated yesterday right Sonya did you
that was mr. Stanley counter item yeah
addendum got it yeah so delaying the
proceedings
compris agent Oh
[Music]
not signing off hard shut down yeah I'll
shut down turn the whole thing off hold
the button in for seven seconds now I'll
just stop it
yeah it needs to be a hard shut down on
the off button name for seven seconds
that's it yeah start it again
I'll start with the yeah right good
evening everybody and our visitors
tonight
welcome to the Development Committee
22nd of February 2018 our usual little
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic suite please don't delay your
evacuation by collecting any belongings
and please don't return into the
building until given permission to do so
by council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded and if
you have a mobile phone with you then
please turn it off or to silent thank
you
yeah item 1 apologies for absence 1/2
councillor my own who's been substituted
by councillor girding counts the Newport
who's been substituted by count through
Rotom don't believe there are any others
no thank you
so item 2 is substitute members item 3
non members attending have counselors ro
Dre unsparing we have number item 4
minutes of the meeting held on the 15th
of February 2018 happy for me to sign
those as a correct and accurate correct
and accurate record of that meeting
thank you
item 5 declarations of interest the
council America
Thank You chairman I have a declaration
of in not pecuniary interest in item 8
the both the applicant and the member of
staff mentioned unknown to me in a
professional community in relation to
being a member of ready Town Council
non-pecuniary interest
okay yes sir oh great
non-pecuniary interest item 8 chairman
camp thank you just for the benefit of
our visitors tonight the way the way it
works
oh sorry counselor Stanley mr. Yu their
number QE interest as all the council
members of the rorish okay the way the
meeting works is that one of our
officers will present the item they'll
then be the opportunity for anyone who's
pre registered to make a presentation
and we've got a couple of visitors there
then our non-member counselors get the
opportunity to speak then it's open to
the members of the committee to have
their debate and ultimately take a vote
although there might be things that you
hear that you either agree with or don't
agree with unfortunately there isn't an
opportunity for public contribution to
the meeting I believe most of our
visitors have come in for item 9 so I do
propose to take that one first if that's
okay with everyone the thing that's not
okay with everyone though is the
computer so I'm going to adjourn the
meeting for a maximum of about five
minutes while it thinks about life and
its position in life
members the application site is edged
read on this plan and is it that close
to the junction of East Road Road and
doors Heath road just to the north of
the site is the building in use as a Day
Nursery attached just to the south is a
building as a window shop and then there
are other commercial uses at ground
floor and these premises here on East
Wood Road and there's a residential flat
is block here and some also some
residential properties in Dorothy strode
to the south and take you to photo one
you see the front elevation of the
building it's a two-story building in
the main but with single-story elements
this is where it went slow last time you
try the digitizer
okay I'm talking about you can yeah
so the photos should come through
shortly but this is the ground floor
plan so this is the proposal which it's
okay so this is the ground floor of the
premises to which the application
relates and you suppose to change the
use from retail to a restaurant and
taking up the entire ground floor in the
main it's a sitting area and there's a
couple of function rooms again for
sitting within part of the restaurant
the kitchens located to the rear and
then there are some customer toilets you
can take you to the first floor plan so
the proposal includes change of use to
provide a one-bed flat at 1st floor
which is this area of the first floor
here a small part of the first floor
would be part of the restaurant
providing a staff rest area and some
stuff toilets take you to plan 5 liters
so this is the site frontage so at least
would rows along the site here and the
proposed is to use the existing vehicle
access into the site off Eastwood Road
with the provision of 7 car parking
spaces on the site frontage the entrance
to the restaurant would be just to the
side here the parking standards for an
a3 restaurant use is a maximum and based
on the gross floor area were to come out
at some 34 spaces 7 spaces are proposed
and this has to be considered in the
light of the location of the application
site where the parking standard allows
for a lower parking provision on site
where you are near a main urban area
with good public transport connections
and other car parks in the vicinity
there this application proposes the same
number of parking spaces as the previous
application that came before members
this time last year that application
proposed an a3 a4 use which was
restaurant and drinking establishments
for the whole building so without any
flatted accommodation and that would
have had a greater maximum parking
standard so the seven parking spaces
here
is no no different in terms of it being
policies compliant with that previous
scheme if I can take you to the extract
from the allocations plan this the the
dark red line bound dark lined boundary
here is the extent of the town center
boundary and the application site is
just where my lights shining there so it
is within the town center of Raley where
uses such as restaurants are considered
appropriate there the loss of the retail
in this incident isn't of a concern
given that the surrounding uses within
the sort of secondary shopping area here
retaining a mix of retail there is a
fast-food outlets just opposite the site
on the corner a number of different uses
within that area it's considered that
the pro to restaurant use would add to
the vitality and viability of the town
center location in terms of the parking
there is a car park in Webster's way
which the short walk from the sites and
also a bus stop immediately opposite the
site on East Road Road concern has been
raised in relation to potential noise
and disturbance to residential
properties some of which are located
within the town center boundary here and
then some on Dorsey's Road just outside
the noise and disturbance from the
restaurants obviously would be limited
by the opening times which I'll set my
condition and also have to be viewed in
the context of the town center location
either a number of restaurant uses with
flooded accommodation above in this area
here and the general background noise
level which would be higher in a in an
urban area the children's day nursery
immediately adjacent to the site is
generally open at different times to the
restaurant although the proposal the
restaurant does propose to open at a
lunch time service as well as into the
evening the impact on the children's day
nursery given that the restaurant use
would be contained within the building
shouldn't give rise to too much noise
and disturbance that would be harmful to
that use adjoining there is a condition
proposed to prevent use of the forecourt
and the rear
garden area by patrons of the restaurant
so you wouldn't have that noise external
to the building associated with the use
the recommendation chairman is for
approval subject to the conditions
stated thank you I have two speakers on
on this one so it's councillor Marissa
really town council with all our
speakers that have a maximum of five
minutes and I let them know when they've
got a minute to go thank you chairman
members good evening
I'm cancer Debbie Mercer chairman of
Roatan Council Planning Committee and
I'm here tonight to reach reiterate the
planning committees objection to this
application we feel the proposed change
of use from an a.1 shop to an a3
restaurant is inappropriate and is
detrimental to the residential area that
it is positioned there has been 22
objections from residents and these were
considered reasonable by the officer but
not considered sufficient to refuse
planning permission perhaps bearing in
mind the number of residents who have
raised these concerns that greater
consideration should be given to the
suitability of this application plans
that will be detrimental to their health
and well-being
by having noise and smell disturbance as
well as invasion of privacy there are
some businesses that flout the law and
watch for enforcement although working
under extreme pressure with a reduced
staff will be unable to act quickly to
stop any infringement should they occur
although the conditions state that the
front and rear of the premises are
excluded from this application how our
patrons be stopped from smoking and
causing a disturbance outside there is
unacceptable internal circulation on the
forecourt they are not enough car
parking spaces for in total designated
car parking one disabled and to staff
most people will not walk from the car
parks in Webster's way or castle
Road it is too far for them especially
in bad weather they will Park in roads
surrounding the area parking
restrictions or not otherwise they will
use spaces in thermos yield and the
rainbow nursery what will happen when
customers or delivery vehicles drive up
over the pavement to find there are no
spaces there is not enough room to
safely turn around off the highway and
the committee disagrees with the
officers opinion stated in the council's
old own document the parking standards
design and good practice supplementary
planning document December 2010 page 53
the parking standards for class 4 use
Class A 3 restaurants and cafes say in
all cases adequate provisions should be
made for the parking and turning of
service vehicles to the sites off the
highway this will not be the case
vehicles delivery or customer will have
to reverse onto a busy road by an
extremely busy Junction back over the
pavement to the detriment of pedestrians
old and young mobility scooters cyclists
and cars an accident waiting to happen
the two staff parking spaces will be
blocked in by customers what happens if
one needs to go home will there be two
staff only two staff who used the car
park working there more the others walk
cycle there are no cycle provisions
available for staff to park a bicycle
even though SPD two point 10.1 states
there should be a minimum of one space
for staff and one covered space for the
resident where he's a designated car
parking space for the resident will they
also have to pay to park at a town car
parks or use the residential streets
there is also no provision as to where
the refuse bins will be placed there
needs to be separate bins for both the
tenant and the restaurant and conditions
put in place to limit any noise that may
occur from any glass that will be placed
in them therefore the Town Council
requests that this application is
refused on the grounds that it fails to
comply with SPD two point 10.1 and the
parking standards do
sian and good practice supplementary
plane document December 2010 page 53 the
parking standards for use class 3a a
three-story restaurants and cafes thank
you our next speaker is
[Music]
evening everybody thank you very much
for giving me this opportunity to put my
objections to this application I was
your sight to let you know that I live
at number four door teeth roads and my
garden is l-shaped and so three-quarters
of my garden joins the boundary to this
property and also my neighbor number two
joins the boundary of this property I've
been in the catering business for over
thirty years
so I know all about restaurants and this
place would be a really good potential
buyer for a restauranteur bearing in
mind a garden is there if you look at
all the restaurants in Raley most of
them want to have diners outside so they
use the front of their properties to put
those couple of tables are we you know
if we change the use of this premises to
a restaurant the next step will be to
use that back garden and the why we were
there for me is the privacy of my our
properties there at one point we are
three meters away from the rear garden
recently mr. Sutton has cleared all the
garden it has trees bushes we now have
the privilege of seeing eastward road
and King George's Park from our property
so it was obviously an intention there
or something to help the selling of this
property for a future restauranteur also
we've mentioned about smokers them more
or less they're going to go in the
garden to smoke and that is then going
to go onto our property and for the norm
today it seems to be acceptable for fire
language as my family and my
grandchildren have to endure that as
well that's something to be considered
and then in the winter nights or when
it's you know getting dark the smokers
need lights those lights are going to
impact on our properties majority of our
residents nearby have animals we have
dogs
any slight sounds or noise we're going
to start the dogs barking we have
families
who are gonna then being judged by the
noise of this property they're going to
encourage celebrations nobody has a
quiet celebration and people when they
drink do get loud I'm not opposing to
people celebrating but I'm imposing
you know there is objecting to the noise
that it's going to in you know not just
on our residents in door teeth but the
older residents opposite and on the side
it's already been said about the parking
again been in the restaurant trade
deliveries don't come at a certain time
they come early in the morning they come
late at night this again is a danger to
all around trying to do a delivery
restaurants by nature open till 8:00 and
so the issue mentioned will impact on
our evenings current use of premises is
9:00 to 5:00 and the garden isn't used a
change of use will have all these
negative effects and potential buyers
will clearly want to use this garden the
change of use will be unfair to the
neighboring community who were here
enjoying their properties first I just
wanna highlight that to everybody and
just to wind up and tries to say that
you know dogs children elderly and all
residents living nearby will be affected
by diners and those wishing to celebrate
with noise and excitement something a
shop does not all not cause or does not
cause at the moment also the question
about waste we don't want to encourage
any rats only problems there you know
we're what has been implemented
implemented about that so these are just
some of my points that I wanted to raise
tonight thank you
so we go to our visiting members first
and counselor Dre
notwithstanding the applications
inclusion within the rayleigh town
center boundary and the secondary
shopping frontage area this application
is on the outer limits of those areas
being within a mainly residential area
which has 24-hour parking restrictions
but no official 24-hour monitoring of
such parking restrictions the officer's
report states that customers of the
restaurant will use the existing car
parks in Webster's wyan Castle Road in
reality I believe that users of the
restaurant will not park in these public
car parks this human nature tells us
that customers of the restaurant will
seek to park as near to the restaurant
as possible which will cause unnecessary
noise and nuisance to the local
residents which includes a retirement
complex and an adjacent children's
nursery the four courts of the shops
opposite the site are also in constant
use by customs of the shops and
residents of the flats above the shops
excessive on street parking can be
detrimental to highway safety and
efficiency the application is adjacent
to the already busy Junction formed by
doors Heath road Queens Road and Easter
Road and the additional traffic would
only increase the possible danger and
nuisance
caused by customers of proposed
restaurant and the occupants of deflect
attempting to enter or reverse from the
premises as there would be little or no
room for vehicles to men
within the site in my view there would
be insufficient parking for the
residents of the flat restaurant staff
and delivery vehicles I note in
particular mr. chairman the absence of
comments from County Highway Authority
and environmental health in addition
there are no details regarding waste
management on-site or detailed regarding
the removal and storage of site storage
of waste from the proposed flat or from
the restaurant in my view this
application if passed will cause a noise
nuisance and disturbance which will be
detrimental to the amenity of nearby
residents beyond that which is
reasonably expected in a residential
area I would urge the committee to
review refused this application okay
down to the row
weary of which the elderly resident
still living
thank you and apart from the concerns I
have for our residents which of course
have to be paramount to us
I do have serious concerns about parking
our officers have already said that
there will be seven spaces and in fact
they say this area should have 34 we
have very busy side roads taking into
account Queens Road which at the moment
has got horrific problems down there
with parking there's accidents down
there happening almost monthly so
parking down there we know it's going to
happen we know people are going to got
parking our main main cow parks and walk
across also concerns of the nursery you
know the children come and go all day
long from that nursery can I also please
ask the officer to have a slide up for
the parking again please
thank you so we see parking bays three
four five six and seven and for my
memory along the side there next to that
on the right-hand side of our picture is
the nursery so how how are they going to
get into that house the residents re
house the nursery mums gonna still use
their area they still going to go in
through that front or is that going to
be redesigned
stinker access to justice
Jason - this bit here
it's it's fairly narrow there's a number
of trees just abutting the foot right
here and then there's an out point here
for the nursery as well so you can go in
and round and out
so obviously this land that's shown here
is within the application site so it's
not for nurseries use and so they would
have to ensure that their parking
arrangements were contained within their
their land and there is the reason in
out access for the nursery separate from
this Thank You Katie um you've hit the
nail on the head it's very narrow this
trees there's a wall there's there's all
sorts there so my concern would be the
children also car parking spaces one and
so how will 3 & 4 leave the property
with one if what if there's car parked
in one and two
so parking spaces 3 & 4 could clearly
only be occupied and then the staff
members stay until the customers parking
him 1 & 2 had left so chairman quite a
mission master really of parking and
which brings me back again to the seven
parking spaces when there should be 34 I
think I've made my points but you know
noise as well for our residents is
unacceptable thank you thank you
that's the sparing Thank You chairman I
think my colleagues have covered most of
the points but I think just to sum up
apart from the other issues already been
in raised I believe the potential
lighting noise in general disturbance
level are in excess of what residents
living in a predominantly residential
area should be expected to tolerate yeah
right okay so now to the members of the
committee counselor step tone you
indicated first Thank You chairman a
couple of questions if I may with
regards to parking there
perhaps officers can correct me if I'm
wrong here is it isn't it correct that
they people parking in there should be
our two ingress and egress this parking
area in forward motion so where is the
turning circle within the car park
do you want another question as well
through it just a lot Ilana okay the
other question was the first speaker
quoted a standard and a reference number
would the officers care to remind us of
that I'll be honest to say I can't
record it from the just from the
reference number that you would take the
speakers and then if you come back with
all the questions
that's a griffon Thank You chairman I
have quite a few concerns about this
application mainly due to the close
proximity of domestic properties and the
retirement homes many restaurants today
are fitted out with widescreen TVs sound
systems they often have entertainment
evenings performers coming music later
on etc it's quite possible in the future
that the rear garden might be used for
alfresco dining also there is absolutely
no question that people will be outside
smoking and while they're out there
chatting to each other
so there'll be some background noise
from that sort of activity as well that
that's all I have to say thank you thank
you the mountain
Thank You chairman it's gonna I'll is it
possible I know it was on in the folder
to see the the picture of the the
photograph taken from the front and if
not could we possibly have a Google
Streetview
Google Maps treatment we will try that
was one thing I was going to ask I just
think to put it in context it helps a
few points I've got bins and waste
management I'd like to have more
information regarding that right 7
parking spaces we've heard that should
be 34 a quarter of 34 is 8.5 so what
they are offering is less than a quarter
I understand the idea that if it's in
the town center there may be fewer
parking requirements we've now just been
told that two of those parking spaces
are for staff so in actual fact there's
only five parking spaces for customers
which I'm not going to do my maths again
but if 8.5 is a quarter of 7 of 34 then
I think that we are really aiming low
here on the parking provision which i
think is unacceptable
are there any conditions regarding times
for deliveries for if it's a restaurant
I guess there will be food deliveries
coming to it are there any conditions
regarding any use of outside or the
requirement for them to have a smoking
shelter that is clearly designated so
people aren't allowed sort of the smoke
where they want to which would cause a
disturbance to the neighboring area I
having heard the the other the town
council speak I do believe having seen
this that there is a real issue here
with noise pollution that is going to be
detrimental to a residential area so
those are the main points but I would
really like to see a street view or the
deer photographing you working on
getting that up that's mrs. hoi
and yeah I just wanted to bring back
about the parking three and four and one
and two I put under health and safety
rules I must be able to exit but I just
like to say coming back to the children
I know he's not part of this application
but when they're you got remember their
room they're probably between so like
birth up to four that go there well when
you pick children are the first thing
they do is run that's what that's what
they do something and my my concern is
that is quite dangerous coming off that
driveway onto especially especially if
you've got driving up there it you're
you know you've gone for meal five you
coming out at seven something because I
don't think people realize how busy
Eastwood roadies I just want you to I
don't know if that is under health and
safety okay thank you
cancer Stanley Thank You chair certain
things have already been mentioned but
there are still concerns um I'd like to
know where the safety area is should
fire start in the kitchen
also the excess or exit of the upstairs
flat we're sure if we've got cars parked
they can't run down the side of the
building as cars are blocking the area
and you wouldn't necessarily move a car
if you've got a fire in there because
that would be the last thing you would
do the exhaust fumes from the cars that
are parked at the car park even if they
reverse into the
area that we're talking about the
exhaust fumes would be to the nursery
and not elsewhere which could which
which could be an environment
environmental health problem I'd like to
know that and also car park number two
seems to be a lot smaller than all the
other ones is that for disabled or not
thank you that's the mountain you've got
your view there was there anything else
you wanted to add
I'm sorry so yeah so that's part of the
building so this this all is the
application site and then to the rear of
those yes obviously if we panned around
door teeth road you would see a
residential property just immediately
you know on the corner behind can I'd
start in terms of when we got that
viewer in terms of the parking there
seems to be a that seems to be a fairly
larger space than than seven car parking
space for the provision was and it's at
the net nursery next door that's the
nursery I saw yeah parking spaces one
and two would have to go on that
property in order to is that correct no
I'm confused about these two cars parked
here
[Music]
in what would be space is three and four
so there are 90 degrees to what the
parking layout shows 90 degrees to what
the parking layout shows and then you've
got another two spaces here what they've
done on the parking layout is left
enough room to entrance the building so
it might look like you could fit more on
but you can't if you want to provide
enough space to turn within that within
the site and then they're going to think
that the parking layout is these cars
will be parked at 90 degrees to the ones
apart there now and you'd have five
spaces along here with the final space
in the position
the lights are sort of shining there
okay thank you counts the Williams
so it's adjacent to the foot way that
would any buildings Williams Thank You
chairman I understand that the parking
at the front is mainly for staff a great
concern they're looking at the
photograph that we have there is that
there is no barrier between the two
properties cars were they used to be
able to reverse or go forward into the
other projects no doubt they will go
forward or reverse that's one of my
great concerns is the security if it did
go through a condition of a barrier I
think would be essential thank you okay
remembers just as chairman there's a
couple of things that don't need to
point out on the the motion for approval
which we haven't got to yet iight 'm for
in the conditions clearly states that
there's no approval for use of the rear
garden at all in connection with this
business so that would be a separate
application so it's fair to say that the
garden is not for consideration for use
within this by condition it's also fair
to say that as a furniture shop the site
is used to deliveries from larger
vehicles loading and offloading things
at a variety of times and that the site
is well-versed in a variety of vehicles
coming and going fraught from the
property it's also needs to be said that
the the proprietors of the the
application site can't be held
responsible for the wait for behavior of
people on a private piece of land
belonging to the nursery however
concerning we may find that it is
private land so I just needed to throw
those things into the equation the other
thing that was mentioned was performance
with
the foot potential for performances
within the property rather than it being
used just as a restaurant then I think
there are licensing conditions which
would be considered outside of this
meeting so I just needed to make those
points would you like to carry on I can
come back on some of the questions that
were raised
I might have audience some of them might
have already been answer so if I repeat
myself turning in the carpark rather
than vehicles having to exit in reverse
gear so they have designed the layout so
that there is a six meter space behind
each of the parking spaces so that would
enable people to reverse and then exit
the bill exit the car park in forward
gear the parking standard for restaurant
uses one space per five square meters if
you take the gross floor space of the
restaurant it includes the first floor
element which is the stuff rest area
it's about 34 spaces that's the maximum
it's a maximum standard for uses of this
nature
there isn't at present a condition
relating to deliveries or delivery times
and it would seem reasonable that the
restaurant would want deliveries to
happen when the restaurant weren't open
to the public
given that you're going to have to
transport all the delivered you know
stock through the restaurant and all
that disturbance to your customers
so you'd hope that the carpet would be
fairly free at the time when the
deliveries were were scheduled there is
a condition as the chairman mentioned
about the use of the outside area to the
rear garden and to the frontage giving
members concerns we could probably
tighten that up a bit
and so that enforcement were very clear
about what it is we're restricting in
terms of customers not utilizing the
outside space in relation to the
restaurants at all not just eating and
drinking but congregating chatting
smoking etc in relation to bin and
refuse of waste management there is a
one meter there is a gate that you can't
just see
this so there's a passageway within the
site to the side of the premises that
allows access to the rear of the site
it's about 1 meter wide and potentially
refuse and waste can be stored again
potentially
in some sort of shelter if that was
deemed necessary we could impose some
conditions around that to the rear and
then for that to be brought out when it
needed to be collected from the site
frontage and that could work for the
restaurants and the residential flats
obviously that both need refuse of
arrangements I had something to do with
a barrier for the car park obviously no
barriers are proposed in relation to the
application there's nothing stopping the
applicant putting in an application for
some sort of barrier arrangements at the
moment I think the openness enables
reasonable use so that people can
function well between the different uses
but this application is just concerning
the land that was within the site and
their parking would be contained within
that area an exit for the existing
upstairs flat there is the separate exit
to the rear of the building
and there is that side passage to allow
evacuation if if and when necessary
Kassem Eric
microphone please
it doesn't seem to be a sufficiently
positive I would prefer something along
the lines that the rear garden or
forecourt must not be used in connection
with the dining bar area without further
permission rather than it being might
give the impression that it doesn't
actually need any approval at all so I
think it needs to be a condition that
counts the hawk way
Thank You chairman it's been mentioned
about smoking and I haven't seen for
many of the site plans is there a
specific designated smoking area now so
they haven't given any indication on
where that may be then obviously that
might have an a bearing on noise and
effective peoples there Stanley Thank
You chair it's still I'm still not quite
clear how the emergency exit from the
upstairs flat yeah
when you've got bins down the side way
and you've got cars parked in front of
the gate
which you will have how is that
occupants or occupants occupant or
occupants going to get out I mean they
can have you can have more than two
people out there you can have four or
five people how are they going to get
air if there is a fire in the restaurant
there is no means of getting air no way
clear of getting away from the premises
if you've got beans down the sword-like
you make it means of escape would be
controlled by Building Regulations or
rather than planning permission on
cancer item
I just like to remind members that some
if you if you look at page 9.5 in the
report paragraph 10 there's a statement
there that says about opening hours and
these can be controlled by a planning
condition now we have had a precedent in
the town center where we have put a
planning condition on which restricts
the hours and the operators of the
premises have subsequently obtained a
license to go on until lord knows what
hour in the in the evening and have had
the license have had the planning
condition removed so I just like to
remind people look they're not all on
Easter okay guys the mountain Thank You
chairman I would just like to say in
terms of the conditions that are I agree
with with with council America if we
could tighten that one and also you did
mention about adding a condition to the
bins and waste storage so if it does go
that way I would like that to be added
as a condition I'm still concerned in
terms of the parking I think there's not
enough parking provisions and the noise
pollution in in relation to being
detrimental to a residential area I just
want to make those two points again go
back to the parking parkings three and
four and one and two would be blocking
in three and four
yes I mean I just fall under health and
safety rules
they had to have an anine in and out no
am I wrong on that but they don't have
to have an in-and-out access arrangement
on to the highway revert so so parking
spaces 3 & 4 would be at 90 degrees to
where these two vehicles are positioned
here and when 1 & 2 were occupied they
wouldn't be able to leave but once 1 & 2
had left they could reverse out and then
out of the site and forward gear
but no barrier here you're concerned
about
Wow
the the application is the application
the application is the application and I
think there we nothing stopping the
applicant coming forward at a later date
and putting an application before you
for such an arrangement how a barrier
would affect the parking arrangements
between the two sites if that if the use
were to go ahead and they want to be a
degree of flexibility in terms of where
people park between the two users
potentially I'm obviously a barrier
would clearly have implications for that
so it's not within the application
before us tonight thank you
remembers I think almost everyone has
spoken on this one and there's been a
lot of points made however at this
moment in time we have then a motion for
approval printed on page nine point
seven which I'm duty-bound put to you
however there was concern about
condition four and strangely enough this
was brought over pre pre the meeting
that the the language of condition four
be amended to make to give the absolute
clarity that there is no condition for
anything whatsoever in the rear garden
and there would need to perhaps be some
informative with regard to bins and the
waste management strategy on the site
and that that could probably be
conditioned so we've got where we are we
know where we are where we stand with
our planning rules and regulations so
members with all know on that borne in
mind those members in favor of the
approval please indicate
those against that item is not approved
I therefore look to the membership
counselor Mountain you know what comes
next I'm gonna move for refusal on the
grounds of lack of parking and on the
grounds that it's a change of use from a
carpet shop that is open during business
hours to a restaurant that is open
extended hours is going to be
detrimental to the residential area as a
snapped oh I was just going to add to
that with the concerns were raised about
the boundaries having insufficient
protection from this saying you against
second in as well yes with the
boundaries between the properties I
think that should be put down that there
is a concern and that should be okay
thank you very much
right members we have a motion for
refusal that has been put and seconded
based on the like the the the lack of
parking in relation to guidance the the
impact on amenity through the change of
opening hours and the concern with
regard to the boundary okay the officers
will insert their appropriate technical
language so those members in favor of
the rejection of this application please
indicate those against that item is
refused thank you our visitors are
welcome to stay for the next hour and a
half but if you wish to leave you may
you don't get out that way right one of
our I believe one of our other visitors
is for item eight which is a technical
referral so I think I don't think that's
complicated so I'll I'm dealing with
that one or our members on dealing with
that one
so item 8 is 15 Kazakh clothes Railly
this isn't one that would normally come
before us but it's because the applicant
has got related to a member of staff so
it's in the application site is located
in a residential area it's the area
outlined in red on on the plan here and
the proposal is for a ramp access to the
front of the property which you'll see
on an elevation can you turn that 90
degrees please plan
there we go so they go it's a it's a
fence so hopefully this gives members a
clear indication of what is proposed the
ramp to access protrudes out from the
building by a meter along the length of
the existing front doors here so there's
a small platform and to turn there are
some stepped points there and that is
the nature of the application I think we
have a street view so you can see the
- need to be slightly higher
so and it's to to this property here so
it will run along along here jutting out
by a meter around the corner to the
front door with a little platform and
sufficient car parking area will be
retained within the site frontage so
that this usually would be a delegated
application but because the applicant is
related to a member of staff it is
before you tonight the recommendation
chairman is for approval does any member
feel the need to comment on this that
council can step toe move the approval
anyone like to second that as members in
favor of the approval please indicate
thank you that item is approved thank
you you two are welcome to stay for the
next hour and a half wish or right now
move on to the substantive items of the
evening item six again just remind
members on our both item six and seven
there's an amount of information in the
addendum which I've checked you've all
had the opportunity to see
thank you so when you're ready
chairman this is a reserved matters
application for the proposed development
of 192 dwellings in association with
phase one or the development approved
for up to five hundred railings white
outline Planning Commission at lands
north of London Road and south of Wharf
Lane railing in 2016 there are intended
to be three phases of development at the
sites
therefore this floats are just the first
phase which is the northern area
immediately to the south of oriflamme
so the area were looking at just this is
on the approved parameters plan is part
of the outline application so we're
going to be looking at the beige areas 1
2 3 these parcels here and the secondary
link road which is here linking to Lord
Industrial Estate Road the site
currently consists of open land with an
existing tree located in a central
position on the site approximately there
the trees it should be noted that the
outline planning application is the
overarching decision which looked at
matters relating to surface from strange
highway implications construction
management and 1:06 contributions to
name but a few it is not for the
application currently before us to
revisit the matters already considered
as part of this outline application many
of which are controlled by conditions
imposed on the outline application the
surface water drainage in relation to
phase 1 in particular has been agreed as
part of the outline application
so the ventline so it covers these
parcels here and then this one right
here just highlighting it so the red
line shows the boundary for the proposal
we're currently considering the mix of
the proposed dwellings would be as
follows so we're looking at 35 one beds
47 two beds 52 three beds 54 beds and
eight five bed units the proposal also
incorporates the secondary access road
so this this link here from more than -
real estate and other internal roads and
accesses there's also an amenity area to
the center so looking at this area here
and to the southeast close to the bound
with the school we also have a small
community section just here there's also
a proposed slight alteration to the
formal housing provision so the key
material planning considerations are
access appearance landscaping layout and
scale on those matters I'm going to go
through just now so with regards to
access the proposal uses a mix of feeder
roads so this is what we'd be the feeder
road here we've also got shared surface
roads such as this area up here muse
courts and private Drive so these are
some of the private drive areas and
access and some of these properties
along here is an example County highways
does not object but seeks conditions be
imposed some are already included within
the outline application but those
considered reasonable have also been
included as part of there was over
matters application with regards to
parking the resident parking space
numbers are here - the cycle parking
position is also adhered to and where
there were no garages or store - some of
the units at cycle parking storage can
be provided in the garden areas and
that's been suggested by planning
condition the number of visitors faces
exceeds the requirements there are nine
spaces within the requirements are a low
cater to certain plots rather than being
unallocated but as the total number of
visitors faces exceeds requirements by
twenty four spaces anyway this is not
considered objectionable County highways
not object to the visitor parking post
thank you
so this is just a plan which shows the
visitor parking arrangements at the site
so all the orange the visitor parking
spicy is the unallocated one so you can
see how they're scattered throughout the
development in locations which are
easily accessible to various visitors
across the site and the power to wheeler
provision which we're going to come onto
we've got a couple of spaces there and a
couple there so the power tweeted
provision is also adhere to and a
disabled baby vision is considered
acceptable subject to a condition
requiring a further space to be
converted to a visitor by so the
disabled Bay's allocated around near the
apartment blocks so we've got some up
here who also got and a few down in this
area as well and the apartment locks
have the wheelchair accessible units
within them hence the reason they've
been located in those areas the parking
base sizes are also adhere to the car
bonds proposed meet the base article at
area and they should be prevented from
having doors as this would then require
them to meet the garage sizing that's
been controlled by condition the
statistic condition conditionally
application the double garages for eight
dwellings and not to the 7 meter length
that we would normally require but these
drawings actually already have to offer
feet parking spaces
so the Gary sizing is not crucial here
because the garage is actually and in
addition to what we would normally see
in terms of numbers on those particular
plots the six meter reversing distance
are also provided
so moving now on to the appearance of
the development on the addendum we've
got five character areas that they're
looking at so there we're having
proposed a rule age which is a section
which runs down this side and across the
font and were lame and so that will be
largest height property is not
sympathetic to the software landscape
and around the area and they're looking
at cottage barn types and proposals in
terms of style there they've also got
well the phone - is this school approach
so this is the areas or coming down
around this kind of area so it's more an
urban in character a lot more terrorist
type units around there this is where
the proposed health care facility
they're not as part of this application
which is in terms of showing you
proximity of the phase one residential
element so what else
we're expecting on the site we've also
got an area called Oak View that's near
to where we've got the oak tree and this
little Lobby green area here Hill green
is the section coming down here where
there a lot of the dwellings are going
to form onto the open space section here
and we've also got some Mews corpse area
there's three of those which more sort
of self-contained and units of
properties so if we could look at plan
three please
so this is the street scene an example
the streets needs looking at on the site
so it's quite a traditional design
street scene three
yes so we're looking at 12 house types
we've also looking that flat over ground
and there's also apartment blocks on the
development so this actually shows so
strictly in one and two
yeah there so the angle looking one is
looking all down that way too is is as
you would drive into the estate you'd be
looking down the road better here we've
got like kind of the detached larger
style properties as you come into the
entranceway and the development in terms
of material usage we're looking at red
and buff brick green render cream white
gray green and black boarding all
proposed County have been signed in
object to the proposal a revised plan
looked to address on the appearance of a
prominent corner dwelling new to the
school and that's been addressed as part
of this application so this is just
another streets in example but this is
actually showing what you would see from
water line so street scene
so street scene three so that the top
element here where you've got the two
apartment blocks forming and this corner
here and then looking across you've got
some senators hatch properties and then
coming further along you've got more
detached as you get some more the
Greenbelt H to the west here so this
just shows what the apartment got to
look like on the on the development
we've got five our apartment blocks
there'll be two in this corner up here
and then three down the bottom here as
well so moving on to the landscaping so
this is an initiative version of what
the landscaping could look like on on
the site so we're looking at various
trees hedge plans and racing and
ornamental shrub planting and turf in
the ceded areas there be one tree
located in the lot of green that's an
existing tree there so that areas been
designed around that tree in terms of
its appearance the council's arborcoat
list is not objects the county urban
design officer considers more details
required and there's more opportunity
for tree planting this can be dealt with
by a discharge planning condition 21
which is attached to the approved out on
application that covered dealing with
all the landscaping matters on the
entire site so the entire outline
development including phase one so we
can deal with a lot of the landscaping
matters getting more detail as part of
that discharge of condition process so
moving on to the layout now and the
elements of the layout we've got and
plan to again please
so the density we're looking at high
density of 38.7 dwelling per hectares to
the east of the access road so this area
here would be the higher density and
area close to the school were you again
you've got the more sort of terraced and
closing it dwellings then we've got a
medium to the northwest corner so this
area over here about 27.9 dividing per
hectare and a low of about 25 point four
to the southwest part of the site as
well and that is mostly in accordance
with what was agreed as part of the
discharge and addition process for the
density Arrangements at the site the
dwelling mix would be from one to five
eight units which is going to be a good
mix of dwellings across the site we've a
got some one meter separations that we
look for there was 33 dwellings in two
apartment blocks that do not quite meet
this requirement however in some
instances this is only some corner of a
dwelling for example and the red still
visual gaps provided through this
guidance through car parking spaces open
grass verges gardens and open space
therefore it's not considered a reason
for a few so and we've considered it
that way on other developments we've
dealt with with regards to residential
amenity
there's no detrimental impact considered
on existing neighbouring dwellings there
were 12 instances where and the 25 metre
and 15 metre separation distance is the
Essex design guide and gives us guidance
on
I'm not provided however the
relationships between those railings on
the development are still considered to
be acceptable the technical housing
standards are met costs of development
conditions were attached the outline
application we've asked the water
efficiency and energy details of those
have been submitted and we are likely to
be likely to be considered acceptable
but we're consulting with a good and
control team I'm on that further
information there were six wheelchair
accessible units and have been
identified as well and they are within
those apartment blocks and we've
identified already down here and up here
and that's in accordance with our policy
and that number of units with regards to
amenity with the layout the flats and
flat over ground units all provide are
the balconies or communal space in the
corners with our policy two of the
dwellings not considered to comply with
a garden size criteria within SPD too
however these still provide gods of 91
and 90s
in square meters and the development and
surrounding strategic landscape looking
at the quantity that we've got
surrounding the development and he's
considered to still provide a good level
of open space for those two dwellings
and it's not considered that but you
justified reason for refusal here the
size of the local greens it's also
considered to be acceptable so the local
greens are that area there which is
joining the the school and also there's
an Eloqua green up here which has been
incorporated partly into the strategic
landscape and there and I'm there
considered to be an appropriate sizing
for the development the lobby green oak
Oak View which is this area here that
we've been referring to is slightly
below the sizing requirement within the
outline application by a naught point
naught three hectares
however the wider site provides a large
quantity open space we've got a no
material amendment applications
submitted just just to amend that and
also the developer has increased the
size of this area which is outside of
the application site so we'll see that
come forward in future phase
applications but that has been increased
to absorb the slight difference between
this sizing that we've seen here we move
on to plan seven we look at the waste
and refuse proposal so this is what we
what we're seeing regards to the refuge
strategy on the site so you can see
these all the sweet path analysis where
the refuse vehicle would track
throughout the development on the site
and all these areas here that's
considered to form an acceptable
arrangement on the proposal bean story
to either be within garages or Weir
gardens and the apollon blocks would
have their own communal stalls to
provide the necessary storage there are
five locations appositive own of where
the drag distance is beyond the 25
meters but in most cases this is still
between 27.5 and 30 meters so that's
considered to still be an acceptable
arrangement and for this size of
development so moving on to the style of
units that were looking at on the site
so the book this is the building height
parameter plan that we looked at and
agreed as part of the outline
application so this permitted heights of
up to three story so 12.5 meters to the
east of the main access road so along
this side here
and up to 2.5 stories or 11 meters in
height to the west of the main access
road but the proposal caught with this
we're looking at predominantly two-story
dwellings across do you stay and see the
the apartment blocks would be the three
story elements and there we do see some
house types a two and a half story but
the predominance is going to be
two-story across the phase of our
development so the last element to
discuss so we've gone through the
various aspects that need to be
discussed as partition reserved matters
application the affordable housing is
just the last element to mention because
there are 68 units required as part of
phase 1 so 55 will need to be a full
rent and 13 intermediate we originally
saw a proposed tenure mix submitted as
part of this application 10 um exchange
with more one big units proposed
concerns arrayed from US housing team
regarding that and as a result we had a
changed that submitted and we're now the
only change were looking at now is
opposed or for one extra tube
adversities one less three bit on the
estate and a four-bedroom units would
now be intermediate rather than
unaffordable in so it we'd still be
looking at 35 percent at affordable
housing a home to policy and we would
still be looking at an eighty twenty
percent split in accordance with policy
and the strategic housing team did not
object to that change that we're seeing
the affordable housing and you can see
is the purple and the orange from the
development so we see we've gotten here
up there and then Mary's on here and
then some more scattering around this
school section here so that's where
people thousands house most likely
doesn't show on a plan where it would be
the applicant has provided the service
summaries members that you may well have
seen just to mention this is not
additional information it's not required
for you to reach a view on this
application it's just an informative to
assist you I mean understanding the
proposal put forward tonight so conclude
this application is recommended for
approval by offices subjecting additions
as shown in their full wording on the
addendum thank you Jim thank you so just
for the sake of clarity
it's the areas within the red boundary
that we're talking about so we need to
focus on those and on the particular
points mentioned on one point seven so
this is a fairly comprehensive
application counselor Steptoe thank you
um a little bit of concern about the oak
tree that's they're asked to imagine
that's been there quite substantial
amount of time and it's very good chance
it might well be there for considerably
longer after the houses have gone how is
that going to be protected from it's
quite adjacent to a new piece of road
that's going in and development how is
that going to be protected it's going to
be screened off and how is the water
supply to that tree going to be
protected because we take too much water
away we're going to lose that tree so
perhaps sir officers can clarify that
for me a little bit and the other
question I wanted to ask the main spine
road that runs from north to south in
the center of the road there's like some
black bits in the middle of the road can
officers clarify what they are please
they can but that element doesn't make
form part of the application no just but
for clarity yeah caster Merrick thank
you German as far as concerns the open
spaces what arrangements are to be made
for their future maintenance
is that to remain in the hands of the
developer or future purchases in a just
get opening I'll get here we'll take the
questions as a group counselor Griffin
Thank You chairman there was mention of
cycle paths are these outside of the red
marked areas I can't see any separate
cycle paths within them thank you thank
you that's a mountain German it was in
relation to affordable housing I
understand the percentage is correct but
I believed our policy was to have a bit
more pepper potting and what I saw on
that map was that there were clearly
identifiable areas the north never eat
shredded wheat northeast and southeast
but there was absolutely none on the
west side of the development and I
wonder I would hope that they would have
been slightly more pepper potting in
relation to the affordable housing thank
you that's mrs. hoy yeah Essex highways
page six six one three four point three
seven war officers please confirm which
at kinetic highways are referring to and
why is where they weren't consulted I
have a basic few points to the one me
turret separation 31st free do not
comply twenty four twenty five meters
back to back twelve do not comply Garden
sizes eight do not comply oak trees open
space is below the sides agreed page six
point three six
five point six to five locations where
bin stores do not comply page six point
three seven five point six six prayer
perhaps individually one of these
failures to comply with our bodies may
be allowed the sheer number of issues
suggests a poor plant development I also
want to ask the question and in your
conditions you've got you've got where
conditions are and you've got number six
security measures rear side exits way to
Terrace units to be agreed incorporating
security code self closing local gates
but there's nothing in this report to
say where those gates are cancer okay
thank you chairman
my my comments relates to what counsel
amounts in stated that we would normally
like to see much more pepper potting of
the affordable housing and it seems to
be clumped in two main areas it doesn't
seem to be as fair spread across the
whole of the development okay cancer
Stanley Thank You chairman open your
attention to page 6.5 4.6 4.5 in the way
of surface water from the both areas or
the three areas where that he's going to
go I notice that there's a moat around
the outside but it doesn't tell me where
that's where it's going to go and how
we're going to deal with that situation
from the from the properties okay
thank you that's right um German um bit
disturbed you just remarked a little
while ago the central spine stroke
access road it's not part of this
application not part of the this can
consideration tonight it's been
considered elsewhere can we not please
somehow ensure that road is actually
built before what using a really large
development and there would be a certain
amount of chaos with Martin rubbish
going out on to Rory's line you know
it's such an essential part of the whole
development I think really somehow we
ought to condition that this road is
built before they do this yeah but it's
not part of what we're looking at
specifically when when can we get the
chance to actually say build that road
first well sort out that detail I'm with
or you can ask the officers after after
the after the meeting about the phasing
of the things right I think we've got
quite a range of questions it's now new
points that anyone wants to make you
get on your list I'll take them off as
you go I think I'm hopefully came here
to cover everything and yes firstly the
oak tree yes that is we had a condition
on the outline application which
required protection of existing trees
and hedgerows on the site so that will
be controlled through that out on
application the details that we'll need
for that um I hope that's answered that
one that's the spine road north to south
and there's like expect shine in the
road was the other one
sorry the dark line in the yes yes so
that the black marks located within the
spine mode it's not something that we've
been given detail on as part of this
application because we're we're not
considering the spine motive it's not
something that I'm afraid I can I can
provide a answer on what that actually
details the spy mode has been agreed as
part of the outline application so I
don't know the detail around what that's
demonstrating and the open space is how
they're going to be controlled we've got
a 106 agreement and part of that
requires maintenance arrangements green
maintenance regiments about open spaces
on the site so that will be dealt with
and controlled through that process
cycle pass also mentioned so there will
be some cycle paths outside of the red
lined area and which is already been
considered separately teas application
it's not as part of this application
however the secondary access road which
yeah
that'll be not so
where we've got the secondary road here
the we have 2 meter wide paths either
side here so these will be able to
provide the cycle division around here
also this is a 2 meter wide pathway
coming through here so that you'll be
able to and provide cycling going
through through that route as well
within the development we've a got
affordable housing in the petter poppin
a pepper potting and I forego to that so
we do have it's not I should mention
it's not for consideration as part of
this application the actual locations of
the affordable housing and we were just
looking at a change proposed to the
slight provision mix change that was why
it was submitted to us this was more of
an indicative information really that
was submitted to it to assist
understanding where the football has
been going on the site we're looking at
the the detail of that will be dealt
with through the 106 application details
which they will need to give us
information on as part of the 106 so we
will need to agree and locations of the
affordable housing as part of that but
it's not considered this is necessarily
objectionable it's not uncommon although
we have pepper potting and we also it's
also the case that often housing
associations like for maintenance
purposes for units to be relatively
closer together in terms of their
maintenance arrangements for those units
so that's why we have a little bit more
collection in some areas on the site
yeah so as part of phase 2 and 3 we
would expect against or further mixing
so when if when you look at it actually
across a whole you'll see further
spacing affordable housing and coming
through as part of later development on
the site and mention was made of
paragraph four point three seven and the
Highways Agency and the Highways Agency
actually are only commonly consulted and
part very large-scale developments they
said they hadn't been consulted on the
previous application but that's not
uncommon and they haven't provided it's
the a12 they're mostly concerned about
so it's it's not something that we need
to be concerned about or consider as
part of this application that they
didn't have consultations probably the
previous application and they haven't
provided any comment on this application
saying that they have any issue as such
so yes so they deal with the main sort
of trunk roads on a new development
which is going to affect the main trunk
roads mention was made about one meter
separations the distances between
dwellings Gardens VIN stores
lobby green about some of those elements
with some dwellings here and they're not
complying and it's still considered even
though there are elements of those
aren't quite met collectively it's still
considered that we're looking at a
scheme which is considered to be
acceptable on the site so we've looked
at that we've obviously looked how many
elements are not quite met and it's
still considered that for this scale of
development for 192 dwellings but
although they might be some they're not
quite met I mean the gardens it's
actually 72 it's it's not considered
that would be a justified reason for a
fuser on the site that's that's officers
view on that element we've a glass of
condition six the security gates where
will they be located but we don't have
detail about us at this stage that's why
we would be putting that condition on
request in that kind of detail to be
agreed and the those kind of units that
we're referring to though yes so it's
like
so it's this kind of area that we're
looking at up here where we've got sort
of links through to the rear access ways
and trying to deal with that kind of
element in sort of making sure we've got
sort of gated accesses it's it's
commonly something that we get from
Essex Police as a suggestion although we
haven't had comment from them on
actually on this application it's
something that we've followed through
from previous applications with regards
to terrorist units so that's where sort
of that comes from will get the detail
that we can then hopefully agree to as
part of a discharge of addition process
with regards to surface water drainage
we have dealt with the surface water
drain over the drainage elements of the
site as part of phase one and within the
discharge condition of condition 34 as
part of the outline application so we
have got a great details for phase one
with regards to surface water drainage
on the site the spying Road with regards
to the building out of that I presume
that was on the lines of the
construction management side of things
was in terms of construction stage okay
and we have a construction management
condition as part of the outline
application that will look at a whole
manner of different elements that we
need to agree to in terms of how the
development will be built out so it will
look at we're loading and unloading will
take place and we're washing facilities
it will look at how vehicles will
maneuver on and off of the sites so that
can be considered as part of that
discharge condition process so we can
look at whether that's a possibility at
that stage but it's not to be considered
as part of this application because
we've got that controlled separately in
terms of looking at as a discharge of
conditions part of the agreed outline
application Stanley
Thank You chair the two points that I
want to bring up not only from another
counselor is about Psychopaths all their
footpaths of the site and where we've
got here six point seven page six point
seven four point one five we're sad say
they are fairly confident what does that
mean exactly
please just referring to the drainage
item and while I've got that part in
front of me and that sort of comment
that we've had from the county lead
local flood authority is when they were
they were still at the stage then that
we were considering the discharge of
condition details so this you'll see
from the date of the comment that we had
in that was in September last year so we
had the discharge of admission details
in they were considering it and so they
provided this comment whilst that was
still under consideration they hadn't
fully looked at it at that stage they
now have looked at it and they have now
agreed that they are happy with the
details that we were provided as part of
that discharge condition request set put
to this application so they there was a
separate process for the drainage
because we had a condition attached the
outline application that had to be
followed the applicant has provided the
detail for the drainage elements as part
of the outline application and a lead
local Florida Authority have said that
they were happy with what they've seen
in terms of phase one and dieter's have
been agreed on that basis okay that's
the mountain
he's still into the affordable housing
but on one hand I do understand
properties
this is just an example that actually
further down the line we're going to see
different locations I fully understand
you know phrase one what was agreed in
phase one now this is phase two but at
what point is this the last time we see
this
three or if not is there any way
I think the the other thing on the
forward one was when the other complete
areas of the site come forward this is
just a hundred and hundred 192 there's
obviously five hundred over the Hat over
the the entire site and as they come
forward it it offers the opportunity for
the head of potting in the mix and sorry
I'm cancer Rotom can I ask you it's the
siting and layout and such of cycleways
and footpaths part of this application
or will it be dealt with separately at
some other time
[Music]
within the we've been the redlined areas
of the development we're looking at now
it is for consideration so there are
going to be obviously other cycle ways
and pathways and you can already see
some outside of the red line that are
proposed to be provided within the
strategic landscaping so the areas to
the north example you can see all
pathways kind of coming around here as
well but that's that's not for
consideration but there are elements
within the developers are for
consideration so you've got to say the
footpath coming through here you've got
shared surface areas which again are for
pedestrians and vehicles to use you've
got the pathways on the main road around
here I'm coming through there is a
pathway along one along one of these
roads to an extent as well so there are
cycle ways and pathways within this
development that are being considered as
well but there will also be ones that
you look at later in terms of later
phases - yes got it yeah
I'm mainly concerned with what one might
call recreational path while he's rather
than access pathways I've had a contact
from from the Essex broadway's
Association and it refers to item paid
for 43-44 item six where they were told
at the outline say stage that
consideration would be given to making
these footpaths cycleways etc up to
bridleway standard and there appears to
be nothing in this particular report
covering that sort of thing so is it
possible that we could condition this in
some way well that's these areas are we
do have condition 11 that says all
independent pathways can be - that's on
the addendum all independent pathways
shall be a minimum of 2 metres wide does
that so I guess that's what you're
getting - so does that make them
Thank You Cass I mrs. hi yeah
I want you to bring up the 1 meter
separation again or whatever I mean
we're gonna have a lot of dinner
developments coming through we have a
policy over 1 meter
separation that we you can't say
developers you don't have to comply with
the one meter separation but if you want
to build an extension you do have to
comply so on that basis I won't be
bugging for this counts the Gooding
[Music]
only shared surface which is running
down the center of the one two three
fourth quarter over here are the areas
wide enough to get the the been vehicles
down we've got we've got the we've had
had that plan Edition 14 as well
remembers we've had an opportunity to
explore the various bits and pieces the
recommendation is printed in fallen the
in the addendum there are sixteen of
them in total with the reasoning oh so
sorry counsel mr. Hoyt I mean can I
recommend with you thought well I'm
moving the approval now that if that
fails then so those members in favor of
the approval on the the issues within
the red line site and the items that are
specifically for consideration tonight
as members in favor please indicate
thank you those against okay that item
is carried thank you
item seven is a little bit more
technical than we normally look at it is
the reserved matters with regard to gas
and electricity substations utility
infrastructure again small amount of
information on page six of the addendum
a chairman this is a reserved matters
application for the proposed utility
infrastructure in association with the
development approved for up to five
hundred dwellings by out land Planning
Commission land north of London Road and
south of war aflame Braley there are six
intended locations for the
infrastructure so this location plan
just shows where the six are just in the
context of the site as it is at the
moment so one two three four five and
then the six one just at the bottom
there the development incorporates and
okay
so the development incorporates for
electricity substations an electricity
intake station and a gas pressure
reduction installation
pri so they are located the intake
substation is down here the for
electricity substations are one two
three four and then the guest guest PRI
and is that one located there the
intakes are the intake substation posts
the southern end of the site northwest
of lower barn farm the four substations
face across the development so one is
within the resident of element of phase
one two along the main spine road so
that's the residential one within phase
one to spine Road and and the fourth
close to the school site within ish and
that's within the strategic landscaping
for Phase one the gas PRI relocated in
the northeast part to site within the
strategic landscaping area
so the gas priv flat-roofed indesign to
a high of 2.25 meters so this is this is
what the the caterpillar would look like
I'm quite modest design and sizing who
have planned for
so the four substations and we would
have three roof design options and so
flat then we've got a gable pitch and a
hip to pitch design the flat would be
two point eight five meters in height
and the picture before point three
meters and the last plan so plan five is
the intake substation that would be the
largest in floor area so and as you can
see that's the largest sizing and would
have a pitched roof to a height of four
meters the key material planning
considerations are layout and design so
with regards to layout we could pop back
to the plan team
so substations one and three would be
located within those residential
developer areas which is considered
acceptable substation four and the gas
PRI within the strategic landscaping
while CCD located within a soft
landscaped areas site visible from work
Industrial Estate Road it's considered
these these would still integrate into
the landscape as they're set back from
the robot between six and nine meters
and are located in a large swath of soft
landscaping they're located within the
most functional positions for their
requirements substation two in the
intake substation are located within
areas identifies as natural and semi
actual green space on the approved
parameters plan for the airline
application access from the spine Road
so that's these two here so there would
be in the the green space however
substation two is modest in size
although it's in a prominent position
and with the use of soft landscaping in
such a positioning he's not going to
consider to be prominent here the intake
substation would be located near to the
boundary of low barn farm
so here it's not far far away from
low-band farm
this property has a collection of
buildings and hedging on its boundary
and the positioning of the intake
substation would not be considered
detrimental to the occupiers of this
property there are two trees that are
created near to the proposer intake
substation however though be located
approximately 24 metres from the
substation and its positioning is
therefore not considered to be
detrimental to these trees the intake
substation with the buildings and
parking areas at lower bound farm as a
backdrop but it will not appear to a
prominent in this location and if we
could pop back to plan for thank you so
there are three roof design options for
the substations it's not considered that
a flat roof design would be acceptable
within quite visible locations and a
pitch gable roof whilst a more
attractive design would create prominent
roofing for these buildings so it's
consider the hipped roof should be
controlled by planning condition here if
we could look at planning 3 the gaspi oh
I building chose a flat roof and if a
pitched hit roof is achievable for this
building that she looks to be controlled
by planning condition and it's a
proposal and however we don't know from
a functional position whether that's
definitely the case so that will be
adapted within the condition to reflect
that the county urban design officers
advise that we should ensure that the
materials for the infrastructure
correctly relates to the parcels within
the development and a condition has been
suggested regarding materials this
applications recommended for approval
subletting petitions are shown in their
forwarding on the addendum thank you
that's our Stanley
with reference to the area where the
school is whereabouts is that substation
on that on that plot and you guys take
gonna take more with the right in the
corner yeah somewhat concerned about the
substation being so close to the school
depending on where the school was going
to be built that's by other pointer ease
that the heights of the roof on the
substations is that the is that the
minimum height as they're designed to
make them less of a truce this the same
in the in the street see also the area
where we're talking about for substation
one is that is that in the grassed area
or a manatee area because if you could
have put substations in you just taking
up the amenity areas that you're putting
them in so thank you Kathy Griffin
Thank You chairman um whichever design
is selected will there be a security
wall or a security fence around the
outside of the buildings thank you
don't come back on those to them please
so we've got to the school substation
and so we're looking at this one just
here it's been positioned there partly
as well for the actual purpose of the
school considering obviously the amount
of electricity it's likely to generate
so it's a functional reason for it to be
located there as well close to the
school site I'm not aware of any
particular concerns of its location in
relation to the school and nothing's
been expressed like that um and we don't
have details yet of the exact
positioning of the school it may be that
they have a car parking area up here or
but it's not something of concern or
consideration really as part of the part
of this application and with regards to
the minimum of height for the substation
we haven't been told that there's a
minimum below what we're currently
seeing having said that it's not the
actual hiding that we're looking at is
not too dissimilar to some of the
garages that we would have on the
overall development of the scheme so a
four meter with a pitch it would not be
objectionable in terms of designing -
its - its total pitch Heights and as
long as it's - a hip - style as well
which would lessen lessen its impacts
we've regards to the substation one so
that one is so we're looking at within
the area of the phase one residential
development it's not with an amenity
space it's been given its own dedicated
area and we've been the residential
envelope so it's not taking up space any
allocated amenity space or anything like
that with regard to security of all
offense around buildings we haven't been
told of anything like that that's being
proposed however commonly you do expect
to see that sort of thing for safety
reasons around those kind of buildings
but we haven't been it's not before us
currently in terms of proposal
I think just in terms of the security
one the security fence is used to be
when you had the old-fashioned exposed
transformers it's the it's the building
itself that they're in that provides
them with the security nowadays so quite
quite technical apart from their
physical locations so members there's a
recommendation printed on page seven
point six and slightly amended reasons
on page six of the addendum those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate those against that item is
carried and I think that's the lot thank
you very much for your time
consideration and thoughts tonight
[Music]